[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then there were three Levon Aronian
went for broke and world champion magnus
carlsen ground down Hikaru Nakamura to
join Fabiano Khurana
in a three-way tie for the Sinquefield
Cup title now two countrymen and Olympic
teammates will do battle for a spot at
the Tour finale in London will it be
Caruana or so exciting playoff action
coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the final day
of the 28 teams single Cup held here at
the same with shah's Club we started a
in the playing hole as we are waiting
for the players to arrive and battle on
the chess board
we have only one matchup left the
tiebreak with between Wesley soul and
Fabiano Caruana to determine who is
going to go to the grand chester finals
in london who is going to win it all
only time will tell
let's go to the studio and start this
exciting day with Yassir John and
Maurice Thank You Christian I'm Jennifer
Suhani and after an eventful unexpected
series events yesterday we are back for
via to call the playoffs
absolutely Jennifer a delight as always
to be with you and Maurice Wow
yesterday was intense dramatic
pressure-filled what to say
it's everything we'd hoped for in the
tournament let's see our final standings
and our three co-champions unprecedent
event in this infield cup we crowned
co-champions and three of them Fabiano
Carolina Levon Aronian and magnus
carlsen all sharing the cop but we
didn't decide everything because we
still have a playoff between Wesley so
and papi gotto camerata for the four
spots in London and we're gonna go to
Tony rich to draw the lots for that
competition yes and we're here in the
playing hall and I'm joined by our chief
arbiter for the Sinquefield cup
international arbiter Chris bird who
will assist in the drawing of lots just
a couple of reminders the format for day
for today will be two rapid games at a
time control of game in 25 minutes with
a 10 second delay if those two games are
undecisive will go on to up to 6 blitz
games in pairs of two every two games if
those are decisive then that will be the
end otherwise we'll continue to the next
set of blitz games time control for
bladezz's game in five minutes with a
three-second delay as well so Fabiano if
you would do us the honors of drawing we
have a black pawn in a white pawn in
this bag and it will determine which
color Fabiana will start with
Fabiano has chosen the black pawn so
he'll begin with the black pieces at one
o'clock and Leslie will begin with the
white pieces they'll alternate colors
from there thank you both very much
players and we'll begin at one o'clock
Thank You Toni indeed a poppy picking
the black pawn we'll start with the
black pieces remember that this is for
the fourth spot on the grand chest or
that fourth player will go to London and
they'll actually face there on the big
teammate is entire Nakamura
but let's let's see how the sync though
cover ended Jennifer three hundred
thousand in prizes how was it split well
the top three as we mentioned earlier
magnus carlsen Levon Aronian and Fabiano
Khurana sharing the title getting 15
grand Chester a points each and 55k
meanwhile we also saw Chakradhar mum uvr
of in clear forth but would really
matter here was a grand chest four
points earned because it really shut up
the standings as Levon in Fabiano we
weren't placed in the top four before
the event snuck in there certainly by
virtue of the fact that car yakin and so
didn't have very good results indeed
that was the case and here's let's take
a look at the format just one more time
for the plate for our audience that's
right what Tony explained it but for
those of you who didn't understand it's
too rapid games to kick things off game
25 with the ten-second delay if that's
split either by a victory for each
player or true drawls we move to blitz
that's gonna be a game five at the three
second delay and we keep repeating that
until a winner and those three pairs we
suspect at that point there might be an
Armageddon but we'll see it when we get
there if we get the unlikely indeed but
this term has all been about the
unlikely happening and maureesa Ashley
is going to fill us in on the record of
these two players well all sports fans
know how exciting it is to have knockout
match up so you have it in baseball
certainly having the Final Four
when you have a shootout in soccer
people know this is what you come and
look
and certainly this will be an exciting
one as well as this is the knock out
before the Knockouts has two players two
countryman vie for the final spot in
London Wesley so who played
magnificently in winning liban and also
very well in Paris he did tank in the
st. Louis rapid in blitz and also here
at the Sinquefield Cup he'll be facing
off against Fabiano Caruana who also had
poor showings in those events but played
brilliantly to win the Sinquefield cup
and come from behind and actually find
himself in this incredible position of
being able to possibly make it to fourth
place but those numbers that you just
saw there really tell the tale what big
scores we saw Wesley with a big 400 in
rapid and also that big lead in blitz as
well will far beyond will be able to
fight off his countryman who was
lightning fast and very confident at
this time control well he's been playing
great all year long and though it's been
a challenge for him at the faster time
controls you see a confident look there
as he will try to book another spot to
London he's already in the world
championship in London he'll be having a
long trip to Europe Barbeau t we will
see if the games are set to begin let's
take a look at how the Grantchester our
standings took out yeah well we
mentioned in Nakamura at the top Levon
Aronian cleared second mvl in clear
third Levon an MBO will face off in the
semifinals in London well Nakamura is
opponent is yet to be determined but we
know one thing it'll be in a Olympics
evening absolutely and in the grand
chess Tour Finals in London they'll be
playing for three hundred thousand
dollars so this playoff match guarantees
the winner of $40,000 payday at the very
least that's right a hundred twenty pay
for first where DK before if the reason
that their third and fourth that there
will be a third place match so
semifinals match and then the two
winners playing in the finals and we
have a third-place match as well exactly
and there you see him Wesley so who has
a remarkable record against American
challenger Viviano
in both rapid and blitz Maurice I like
to note as well when you looked at the
prize money there it was when karo see
Cara won two events on the tort right he
won both the Paris event and the st.
Louis rapid and blitz he also placed
okay in the first one but not in the
loving event but not great in this last
one
his total prize fund is on all those
four events is less than winning London
mm-hmm I mean imagine that four events
total turned out to be less than that
120 K so you know why those players
really wanted that London spot that's a
heck of a payday if you win or come in
second even last place is 40k that
they're playing for right now just
guaranteed 40k that's not bad a little
bit of extra work two or three hours to
know that 40k is gonna be in your pocket
at least with a possibility of another
eighty on top of it so that's big ride
days these two really would love to have
that spot in London absolutely in the
prestige of being the grand chest or
champion for 2018 what is that worth the
fame and the accolades that go with that
as well
looks good on the CV well remember no
note that Magnus Carlsen has already
repeated as Grantchester champion he did
it twice right Ken Wesley pull that off
exact he's already won in 2016 it's a
can he pull it off this year as well
well he'll get a chance if he gets in
and he was saying how well he was
playing it down a little bit his chances
of going in and he seems really
despondent yesterday in the interview
just resigned to the fact that he wasn't
going to make it and suddenly all things
broke his way and he's here and he gets
his chance so it's I don't know what his
in his spirits were lifted what he was
told
hey buddy boy you got a playoffs
tomorrow him but you got a
it is all because this could be a real
feather in his cap no doubt disappointed
by the turn of events as when he
finished his game he thought that there
was a good chance he was just going to
get clear first exactly with me the
players but he said maybe there is a 50%
chance that one of the two of them will
win right even less than that exactly so
because at that time it looked like
retook was doing pretty well and the
game between a Nakamura and Magnus looks
so Drollet so without a single move
being played the emotional swings that
both of these men have had 24 hours 22
hours or whatever it was exactly 30
pretty high swing absolutely and there's
the handshake I noted that Frank
cammarata the game chess set designer
for the Sinquefield
Cup set as well as the founder of the
house will start maybe opening
ceremonial first move and now deep to d4
and away they go the playoffs are
underway Jennifer big game
I think big match for Fabiano I know it
sounds maybe he's won everything what's
the big deal
he's got to start showing that he can
fight in rapid because if he ties Magnus
in November in the classical portion of
their match he's gonna face relentless
pressure from him in the rapids
precisely and he's currently number 12
in the world and rapid as Magnus is
number 1 he's even worse in blitz
he's number 19 in the world and Magnus
is also number 1 so I think he's gonna
have to start showing something here or
the pressure is gonna be on for him to
defeat the world champion in the
Classical period classical portion well
it's a fantastic training for a pizza
and blitz for fabbi as he's going to be
preparing that before his match and
money he's already started of course but
there is a chance of a playoff and you
cannot simulate the conditions of the
freshing
a chess clock at a competition exactly
so this type of a competition is ideal
for him in this training and we've seen
a can you accuse me of looking at the
past we've seen a catalan with 96 and
then queen a fortune queen April I was
about to say check it's not a check it
is a wipe intends to recapture this pawn
and I think they should be a chevy board
check was played followed by Bishop to
d2 right and all very standard stuff
thus far Maurice and then Knight to d5
okay
protecting the bishop and the capture on
b4 and of course Knight takes before now
white would like to capture this pawn on
c4 so if you play a move like a to a3
just keep in mind that after b5 this
square c2 is weak so what's the
cassadee's is plain enough
yeah yes and it suggests castles and
that is what Wesley has played note that
Knight takes on b4 for those who record
their chess moves during their
tournament games as you're obligated to
they don't have to write Knight D takes
on before because 9c takes on before was
illegal so Knight takes before was is
sufficient you're going for extreme
accuracy and yours no no score taking
those youngsters out there here
absolutely are learning still and even
some adults who are learning the
notations and may wonder about the solid
ease of it but that's neither here nor
there at this moment is now the move
rook to b8 has been played with the very
transparent threat of b5 absolutely p7
b5 which would not only protect the pawn
on c4 were game a tempo against whites
Queen well note that the engines like
white here after Knight e5 I assume no
95 just simply
Knight to c3 and stopping beef I for the
moment continuing the game at the moment
white is and after a 693 6 and then 95
Oh get in the move Knight c3 provoke a
six and now 95
although b5 is answered b5 is I got a
knight I've got exactly so that would
buy well ok so if we continue and up
Bishop d7
I'll take take I'll recapture my pawn
and I'll be standing with an advantage
Knight 283 what has been placed on the
board night 8 3 the engines don't like
this move after castles now Knight takes
on c4 is not on tab he's not playable
after castles because of the move b5 +
95 also has no real danger but looks
like he was ready for this idea after
castles castles on the between b5 was
played uh-huh sidestepping the trick
that you mentioned Knight takes e4 would
walk into a fork pawn fork with d5 so
Wesley anxious to recapture his pawn has
just played the move Queen on a4 to b5
Wow in the sharp b6 on the board
b7 b says 7 b6 Queen takes c4 and Bishop
to a6 right hammering on this diagonal
has about say diagonal the only one way
to el only one move I got a block the
threat to my queen with the move Knight
d5 Grandmaster yeah grandmasters are
both loathe to walk into South pins but
that's simply obliged there's no good
that there's no choice and very quickly
look at how Fabio's playing as well the
players are just blitzing out these
moves and remember it's a rapid game
with 25 minutes they've only used
roughly speaking 1min
sorry what - is it probably something
simple night before here why is that not
possible night take stick with the night
right this guy is yeah oops okay but
Queen e8 is setting up for tricks and
this is still in theory a for at least
praxis which has been played five times
already is move Queen e8 there are
various responses it doesn't seem as
though this trick is any there's a real
trick given the hanging night on beef at
the moment so you can only see one in
this position as discovery is not really
there
rook I've seen one protecting the Queen
loading up for some counter tactics with
Knight take c7 so awkward these two
nights it's like we have tactics but the
Knights keep getting in the way at the
back there really well if the move
Queenie aid is ineffectual though
Maurice we may be the best move here and
then how does blinder Knight d5
answering the problem of the knight on
b4 I'm being prepared to capture the
knight on d5 after you take on on c6 and
rook c6 Bishop takes on b5 and black
gets out of the woods
what's the what's the prognosis after
which I guess we have to play with c2
pressure on the sea lion and easy play
in the center
yeah but Wesley is giving a deep thing
to this position either he knows the
theory and just wants to set himself or
he thinks that Fabiano has got something
waiting for him is Fabia's obviously
playing very quickly indeed he has and
maybe Wesley's a little bit afraid of a
novelty dropping on his head right and
if I'm of the opinion that Queen e8 has
no tactical to it let's put it that way
and your blacks idea of unwinding is to
retreat the Knight to d5 and only then
threaten 98
what if i take the contrary in road by
the way rook FC 1 was played I was going
to say I could play E for and the
position I was looking at this is also a
very nice advantage for white because
I've got the C file and these black
minor pieces don't look so good right
the main that the main move rook c1 has
now been played and 95 very quickly so
both players showing their familiarity
with this line of the Catalan and there
is the endgame of kweisi 6 waiting it to
appear right so we even anticipated all
of these captures a moment ago this
knight on d5 in the line I was shown was
over here on a 5 but it's all about the
C pawn right - I mean if white can
hammer and keep this c7 pawn backward
pawn they'll have a long-term advantage
I don't know but this just it feels much
easier to play for white well
interesting because of the dynamics of
the position that black can play the
most c5 in this rook on b8 in case of a
double capture and we do have this
interesting ending up here on the board
he must surprise he's hesitating right
here the Queen must be captured for sure
but they did the 10 second delay
so using holiday I think he's using more
than all of it you keep in mind that
sometimes it's why is to use the 10
second so that you can think about the
position that will occur later
absolutely but it's not like the
increment you can't you don't it doesn't
add to your pot right so that's the kind
of strategic thing with the delay but I
think as the get used to it will get
better to avoid it a little better than
they have knowing how to explain all the
different time controls and I think some
of the other players they it takes them
longer to try to think figure that out
that they do get it right to adjust to
that
now we could see a position reminiscent
of yesterday's game that Magnus had
against e Caro with the pawn on c5 being
weakened as c5 is playable
yes yeah you're gonna face enormous
pressure on that sea lion no matter what
you do and II for is coming to try to
win your pawn on c7 so you need to
resolve this issue quickly before you
get into some kind of terrific bind now
after takes on c5 white will not take
again because of this position it's
totally the actual way black black
doesn't want to take immediately
according to the engines a better move
is the move rook F to c8 slip in that
little tempo and you always have the
idea of a night before popping in as
well depending on what you do next
because of course you move your rook
then you might see a night before up
here on the board and then aides who's
gonna hang in some tactics already
flaring up on the chess board so this
isn't an idea if Bobby had prepared all
of this to this position I would dare
say he should have prepared even more
because this position is pretty much
forced and you don't want to say okay
now I start looking at a loss or worsen
or worse ending right yeah I don't think
you can prepare as many moves as he has
up to this point which is move 17 it
might seem like okay when you got to it
you could stop preparing now but if
you're gonna force this position it
seems to me that you should know how
you're getting out of it because at the
end of it you look and you say there's
some pressure we all look at it and we
don't like rook on the sea line I don't
need five pawn on e4 visually long
diagonal so if you prepare this it seems
odd that he's thinking right now well
exactly
Catalan players would rejoice if they
could get in lose like 95 to 96 so c5
looks like a must move by the way and
here I'm just having some doubts because
I mean if I play a move like a 3 and we
have rook c8 and I play rook c1 you I
really like him White's position if it's
my turn and it's like I don't want to
walk up the board and walk into a
position where my rook gets ensnared
so after c5 this captures rook F c8 how
could I make hay out of this position
Knight to D for opening up my bishop
you'll take my pawn on c5 I I guess
Maurice
takes Knight takes rook takes we've got
the imbalance of the rook after c8 which
is a very nuanced move a timing issue
that's quite critical here defending the
pawn and preparing night to b4 and that
move prevents your rook on a1 from
moving without in calculating those
tactics and if he can chase you off the
C line then you can play c5 and capture
with a rook and not weaken his pawn
structure at all
that would solve all his problems well
that line that I was just looking at
with c5 takes rook F c8 in this line of
play white is given the option of 94
which is a very useful move it it
attacks the bishop where the gain of
tempo and opens up the view of the
bishop on g2 so I like this move rook on
f8 to c8 preparing c5 without allowing
any Knight d4 sudden move like that
that's a strong move and if anything
white might have a sliver of an
advantage but only because of space now
not because of that weak pawn is it
looks like he has a way to come Crete
Lee solve the problem of advancing that
pawn without creating any weaknesses in
his position these structural weaknesses
he could get in c5 that's gonna bad
cause without any cost that's me yeah
you're gonna not have much as white
it'll be optical only as black's pawn
structure is so extraordinary solid that
he'll have nothing to fear all right
let's see what I could do here for what
this move Knight before the more I look
at it the more bothersome it appears to
me I mean it's really an annoying move
imagine I play a3 Maurice the problem is
I'm 5 how do you in this exact moment
Bishop a4 I guess it would be for you
you could not could go back to c1
I'm sure you gonna be thrilled by that
I'm gonna play c5 okay rook D to C 595
again I'm looking to get this kind of a
cattle an ending where I'll capture I'll
make the trade of my Bishop for your
knight
now put the knight on d3 Allah o
Sanderson and then I'll try to make some
pretenses of being better here you if I
give it to you I could also move my
knight now Knight back for exams just
wondering if I can move it somewhere and
deal with that position
it does feel yeah that moved Knight a
Bishop a4 is disturbing I must say and
this position I'm being told did appear
in a game between vidit and boo both
very strong 2700 players in China in
this month recently played I probably in
the giant chess league I know that you
had a super tournament there and this
position has been seen okay so far be up
on the latest wrinkles as Wesley is deep
in thought now trying to figure out
exactly what to do just shows you the
depth of preparation the awareness of
latest events by the top players as
openings are being played by the best
players all over the world okay let me
be my most direct self play Knight e5
eyeballing the c6 square I'm more or
less expecting you to play c5 would you
do that Maurice has been played by the
way a c1 were concerned about night
before for a number of reasons and this
move is certainly a possibility Knight
to be four it looks like he's thinking
he can bring his route back to a1 and
give me the pawn as well yes no no no
because he but now with my rook already
established here I got this guy's know
so we're looking at c5 as a prelude to
this move Knight before so
it's in this variation that we we were
mentioning that a to pon being
vulnerable right yes and Wesley's move
is a new one this is a legal team
deviating from the game this move route
to c1 and so fabi's on his own now and
will one chassis why didn't visit late
and he understands that he could play c5
takes and now we expect to see night to
be four on the board and even if he
loosens even if he loosens that position
no it is night before off the pawns on
c5 even if he does that it will not be
enough for white because black is
getting serious counter play down the
beeline okay so yeah what do we take
with now yeah exactly five let's imagine
rook there just for a moment rook takes
rook takes pawn takes and this is once
again that pawn structure that we saw
between Magnus and Hikaru from
yesterday's dramatic final round a
imagine a move a to a3 attacking the
knight my idea is if you go back to c6 I
want to try to put some pressure on that
c5 pawn also you're giving me
opportunity to land on d7 Knight to d5
oh sorry after whoopsie - can I get away
with playing Knight see for thinking
that I'm a - is hanging exactly exactly
II - would be hanging rook takes e5
Knight takes is in bad shape as well so
do these two things cancel out well I
got this guy under attack
Maurice was mentioning that you've got
some pressure along the B file I can
deal deal with that pressure and then
try to play with the aid activating
threatening would be one but let me get
an h4 that's I like space all right
that's good here black better way to
handle himself
yeah that night on e2 is not an obstacle
oh yeah so what odd how white her
Knights on
the fifth are really good the sixth are
really are amazing but on the seventh
are usually nothing nobody close your
night on the seventh and sing oh this
one's gonna sit here for a long time we
could work around that it's too close to
the Arcanum eight six six are great only
because the guards are square but not
not before a long term pressure and
tactics usually the night on the seventh
ring how about another 2 up and 1 over
yeah it's reaching too far gone the
chessboard when it does that so you need
you prefer it on the 6th but this line
guys if we go back yeah if we go back in
this position and white crashes through
on the 7th rank something that fab you
so this is the current position and yes
move the mattock here though there's 65
let's play that move okay rook takes e5
a 30 Knight back and this move rook c2
you have to be careful about the move c4
c3 c5 c4 ok so what is overstating it I
can't play Knight here I get that
because of Knight d4 right and he's
taking on I was just looking at that but
I was about I was about to reject it
frankly the reason I was about to reject
it was after Knight takes a to rook a
one night drops back to before rook
takes a 7 and I was thinking well I've
conk
conquered the 7th rank is strong that
I've posted up on the 7th rank before
black is black is gonna have to deal
with ideas of 9595 should he take this
pawn I'm a little reluctant to do this
let's say Knight e5 this just looks like
a nice advantage and it's not an optical
one rotates as possible there as well
yes ok rook takes c5 so you're hitting
my back
ranked and I don't want to necessarily
block that check with my bishop you also
guarded the e5 square very importantly
keeping the night off the fifth and your
bishop is guarding the seventh rank for
the moment right Wow
so let me throw an H for idea
straightforward idea of Knight g5 as
well as giving my King a little looked
from any checks on the first rank of h6
here
h7 h6 now can I make a of this situation
that Bishop is so powerful on b5 there's
no bad nose anymore and whites minors
are struggling to find little vertical
struggle okay and if I go Knight d4
those are the only ways to go then
you've got rook d8 as a counter to my
Knights jumping Black is fine here rook
a seven is is also only optical that's
the challenge in chess right these
optical moving he's stopping to look at
and he's done it he has in fact taken on
a seventh the engines much preferred
night to d4 in this position to play
Knight d4 instead of what he just did
which was capturing on a7 what in but in
all lines it's only giving a slight edge
so white not really giving white much
Bishop e8 playable there and then if you
take we already looked at rook takes on
c5 yeah well I'm I'm all for moving that
knight on d4 and opening up the bishop
on g2 Kings Indian defense players Boone
fell defense players Catalan players all
love to have a bishop that has a
wonderful view on the long diagonal but
okay rook takes c5 you mentioned Murray
says protecting the e5 square very
important threatening a check out on the
first ring and challenging white to
improve his minor pieces a sharper even
sharper given that White's be pawn is
now has now been weakened even sharper
is the move Knight to c6 that's even
that's an ambitious move actually Knight
to c6 chasing your oak not allowing the
doubling on the rank and also preventing
95 and they capture on c5 with the beep
and saying all right someday you might
win my c-pawn but I've got my own
counter play as well so this is a sharp
sharp ish I guess way to play rook c5
looks so solid looking five since I got
the black pieces I get a draw and then
I'm going to hunt you down for the title
with white reminder that this this game
between Wesley so and Fabiano karana is
to determine who gets the coveted four
spot to play in the grand chest for
finals in London in December but I think
that indeed Murray is if Bobby gets a
comfortable draw in this game with black
it's all about that second game getting
that crack with the white pieces
absolutely and it would be a big
confidence booster because as we came
into our show welcome to those who are
joining us a little bit late Maurice had
presented how in the past the record
that each player has against one another
in both rapid and blitz and Wesley has a
formidable record in his favor and also
the position yes I mean this is a really
comfortable position and Fabi seems to
have found a lot of precise moves like I
love the whole c5 a night before idea
yeah and Maurice but look at the clock
he had that two-minute edge at least on
the clock and he's allowed in this
position for his time to go below
Wesley's for the first time in the game
and Magnus has shown that the great
rapid and blitz players when they get
you behind on the clock they start
trending that way and a couple of
challenging moves could push you over
and start prompting some mistakes I'm
surprised that he chose this moment
maybe he feels like it's the
hypercritical moment to look at and
calculating all the possibilities and he
has played Knight to c6 the sharper of
the moves but he's gonna have to be very
careful watchful of his clock situation
as Wesley is incredibly practical in
rapid chess its act I would not be
surprised to see Wesley just drop his
work back very fast because saying in
the heart of the position is
look looking dubious Indiana but still
let's just watch that let's just watch
the clock management because that's
really the great players they we talked
about this yesterday don't let the
perfect be the enemy of the good
because you start looking to for the
perfect moves your clock especially in
this time control just simply evaporates
and you wonder where did my time go and
you start making critical judgment
mistakes the way Nakamura did yesterday
you play that ending in just such a
strange fashion and remember of course
that Levon Aronian when he played that
incredibly bold rook sacrifice rook
takes f7 he admitted that he was also
doing it because only nine minutes on
Sasha's clock at that time yes and there
was so many practical problems that /i
was going to have to solve with very
little time it goes to show that there's
still so much to improve no matter what
level you are at chess and that should
really encourage you because if you're
sitting there and you have an avatar
rating you can start anywhere yes one
thing that we really noticed a lot about
this tournament and the rapid and blitz
was the end game and how important it
was you mentioned the Nakamura game yes
yes and I saw grab master to still
actually pointed out that there was an
article in American chess magazine I
think by Fishbein about that exact
endgame no MBA lost in an article so
yeah these these endings that have
popped up and then there was blue Cena
position and at the game with that
Lucina and Philidor MBO game yesterday
that Korea can successfully defended
it's just encouraging to those of you at
home learn these endgame basics because
even very top players in the world are
messing them up so if you know them well
think about how you're just gonna
dominate yeah well I think I think that
end games have become even more
important in the computer age because
players now can make sure the openings
are tight I remember many years ago my
trainer when my path to becoming a Grand
Master Gregory cried out off he said
it's almost impossible to get
just white these days because players
with black just keep putting the moves
into the engine and they're finding ways
to save positions that used to be
enormous pressure on black that black
would run away from so these days the
openings are mattering less and the
later stages the middle game and the end
gains are mattering more that's why
someone like Magnus as we see rook all
the way back to a1 still holding that
piece though still holding it holding
the rug kind of like curling out right
someone like Magnus whose endgame is so
proficient so precise so relentless he
can take positions that he says yeah you
know it's equal I know it's equal guess
who's the better player that can
lengthen the endgame we see Magnus you
do quite often I say hey we have the
increment let's make this a longer game
absolutely longer the game is the more
benefits a stronger player that's why
some people say that the game of Go is
even more skill oriented than chess
right I mean I don't know how you really
define that but what they're saying is
that there's a longer game and the more
moves that there are the more chances it
is for the better player to show their
dominance absolutely I'll keep opposing
you problems each and every time now if
you answer all all the questions well
okay you get your drop but just slip up
just a little bit give me a little bit
something and I'll keep pressing and
pressing and we've seen Magnus do it
it's almost like a kind of a dark magic
out of nothing but that said also gen I
think that if there were no time on the
clock let's say there were no increment
right it would be even more advantageous
for Magnus because his endgame skills
are so proficient right he's so good
he's so natural that the less time he
has the more he's going problem I see
what to do do you another problem and
you're going oh my god I have no time
extra to even think about these problems
so I think what as long as you have that
end games
in your pocket you could put any time on
the clock you're going to make people
suffer
you're lucky about now is that there's
so many different ways to study the
endgame we had a question from a caller
we had a couple questions about the
endgame but I have so many different
suggestions go on to chess comm or your
other favorite server to play chess and
play it and gains out against the
computer of basic end games study books
make flashcards make your own chess base
file there's so many training programs
to before tactics or positional and end
game by the way I'm not quite sure I
understand it why did Wesley withdraw
his rook all the way back to a 1 when it
had been nicer on the a three squares
that's a good question work a3 was the
engines first choice in that position
and I guess he just didn't want to be in
the range of something or maybe to
protect his own back row maybe looking
at one day or one I guess a three you
can go to c3 but D three is off the menu
well for sure and then and after by the
way I like this move also h7 h6 very
much that limits whites Knight whites
Knights not jumping I was about to ask
you about that well it's because you've
been the LightSquared bishop yeah
sometimes you choose to play g6 because
you don't want any back rank issues but
in this situation now that bishop f1 has
been played
there will be no back rank issues at all
as the train has been effectuated on f1
well I see the movie
h7 h6 not only to stop the jump Knight
g5 there may be on a good day to play g5
g4 and try to escape the night your own
Knight to f3
I see the bishop on b5 as being better
than its counterpart so I would have
played Bishop f1 that was the choice of
Wesley as well we've seen a trade and a
king has recaptured and this end game is
very very even to be short and easy for
black easy no abortion about it the
worst that can happen is a trade OB for
C right pawns that is and snowing like a
move like rook b5 the diamond rooks
showing my rook b5 looks very simple
showing my willingness to trade this
pawn on c5 for this pawn on v2 no this
is just just equal yeah they offset
absolutely no question usually the c5
pawn is weaker than the beach upon but
once pieces get traded they're equally
weak because it's just as easier to
target be to a c5 right now the only the
only thing I will say that would be the
Joker is if by some miracle you went and
somehow the King got to c12 faster than
you could pile pressure up against the
b2 then it's a test you are king
hydroplaning across the first yeah get
that King over to c1 and then there is a
potential that the c5 pawn could be more
vulnerable than the B to pawn but since
that's not gonna happen
I see the whole Queen side going off and
then I'm seeing just four versus four on
the Kings side with an extra pair of
night showing you were drawn this game
like 99% okay I agree somewhere between
50 and 99 the issue now I think as far
beyond I was looking at his vision again
his clock ticking down I think Wesley
has resigned themselves to the fact that
he got nothing out of the opening and
I'm talking about this position right
now oh yeah
it's now a draw yes he knows he can make
a draw easily issue right now is what is
Fabi thinking are you thinking okay I'll
just make a draw easily as well or will
he look - milk something
what really looks like a daddy's
position well I mean from fab ease for
new video again it have to be a very
good day indeed these ideas of 95 94 93
the problem in such a case is number one
you've got a you're releasing lights
night to jump in the center probably and
rook d7 most especially can come into
position that's that's not what you want
to bargain for so I'm thinking oh sorry
I was thinking rook on a CA to b8 you
know chop off those pawns as as quickly
as possible
I mean this is just easy peasy
liquidation only if Robbie thinks he can
maybe somehow play for a win but the
liquidation just looks so obvious here
that so just like I'd say you know what
there's nothing here let me just make a
couple of moves I would not let my time
take down unless Wesley was he can't
even offer a draw so he's not allowed to
do that so that's also in the Blitz you
know I would assume that he that that is
the case but now the move King to f8 a
very good move
bringing the King toward the middle as
well I just don't see why he wouldn't
just think this is equal this is gonna
be no problem for me
and I'm gonna get the white pieces next
and go for it with that rookie 5 was fab
ease move and then Wesley made a move
you know it's funny the Wesley didn't
play this opening yesterday yes right
he's books on see anyway the C file yeah
rook DC 2 has been played King f8 rip DC
- yes I mean what do you agree yes not
now but like yeah no no a patron feels
today gave Wesley absolutely Zippo zero
nada and here he's well early
has not much but earlier in the day and
it really seemed like one of those
nagging Catalan well maybe it's just
personally I've always had issues with
playing against though things like the
Catalan but it does feel to me that when
we see that opening black struggles yes
more than in some other lines yes you
have to be very accurate a very precise
in fact the the Catalan is kind of like
one of those slow build-up and you know
if you're black and you have any
contempt for the cattle and like oh this
is nothing nothing nothing shown that
many a time it's got a good dollop of
poison in it for now then we could see a
repetition now by the way the move
Knight to be for hitting the rook on c2
the rook can go to c3 obviously because
of a 94 has been play route cannot go to
c3 because of night to a to whoops
that would be crying and gnashing of
teeth but and also the move Knight to
rook to c4 could be met by the move
Knight to d3 causing some issues as well
as we see another fork so in this
position it would be wise for white to
play the move rook to d2 and black could
now drop back with 9 to c6 and say would
you like peace and this move is the
other movie could play to try to get a
repetition this doesn't go for position
after I'm sorry 1994 and rook a5 attack
my rook I attack here look what's the
problem the pawn on c5 is pin 98 c2
Knight takes be fired right and Knight
takes c2 Knight takes d5 and night
before forcing night to before and then
we could play for example Knight to d6
calculating
I have a propensity alight from the
English opening cuz it Blackheath and it
protects the only weakness on v2 that's
actly and he has played that move he's
10 surprising he had them over ok 5
which was better in that position for
him so later ok 593 looks tricky but
after rook to a - there's nothing here
for for white but this is why Bobby
decided to play rook e8 instead of our
night before perhaps much more accurate
okay so now we're forcing the trade ok I
can't because it takes me to this is why
Bobby did it because well remember when
I was saying if we could hydroplane
across to the first rank
it's a c2 c4 does that help just put a
king on d6 and this is the drug Darren
but how they gonna make the draw will be
interesting because there's no if there
is no draw offer then there won't be any
repetition in this position that looks
very obvious maybe King c4 room before
checking some can't move backed in order
to do it but I think they're both very
aware right now that this position is
drawn oh we have nine eight three nine
eight three okay so the idea I can and I
can imagine for Wesley is that he's
thinking his king is in the box and the
square pardon me and that if you push
your pawn it's just a vacuum the a the C
pawns are going off and we're gonna see
a draw night before is also playable as
supposed to 96-83 okay in order to get
the similar idea night before and if you
take on c5 visibly 93 well this is a
position I would like to play if I were
white because if I can set my night up
on c4 and blockading your partner know
he's I like this I think that this is
the easy most solid choice by favi we've
seen this night Trey it's on the board
and now it's
rook e8 or repeat 343 get active and
then work a1 you want to put your behind
the pass pawn but you kind of hunt the
Potter to be a little bit more further
advanced when you do it they certainly
do and I've been informed that draw
offers are allowed at any time in the in
the Rapids in the playoffs in the
playoffs your offers are allowed at any
time which is interesting especially
since it's being televised that I would
hated they drew it in two moves well if
we see rook takes arrive and rook takes
a three that's okay wow it was a very
well played game Wow or both very well
prepared yes it's interesting that we
could have seen this game yesterday and
they're all important in field Cup class
but to maurices point with a move pair
the pressure is on when you're when you
have the white pieces we're never gonna
see a quick draw offer no because
there's not because you really need to
try to make the most of your win with
your white pieces right remember that if
Fabio only draws his right the game then
we go to blitz and we know that that's
not necessarily Fabiano's craft rings
yeah try to win in the rapid right with
a free cracker with the white pieces so
he's gonna try it's very hard as when I
look at this game and I see how smoothly
Viviano was able to neutralize White's
opening advantage I'm I'm reminded of
maurices interview yesterday with Wesley
where Maurice is saying well didn't you
want to get play and and a kind of
question from Wesley is can you show me
how how to get play and that he even
thought of playing 1 F 2 F 4 on move one
yesterday because he's it that's the
problem of how do you get a position
where your opponent number one isn't
completely familiar with it number two
gives you presumably the better quality
opportunity to show your stop and we did
mention that Leslie had a chance to
qualify even with a draw it's just that
there were many more scenarios where
would have gotten in there exactly but
now of course he proves everybody wrong
in terms of wanting of the big box
arrest exactly
he found themselves in this position
rather than trying to over press with
white exact what would happen if he had
lost who's that wisely that's a good
question because Nakamura also lost he
would have gotten to play off but I
believe that it's not gonna wear a head
drawn he would have been out to me now
by that slick point because favi would
have gotten edge more Grantchester
points yes a draw by Nakamura yesterday
guaranteed babbies road to London well
also if so losses and Nakamura drew I
think they would have had the same
number of points that's the idea that's
why losing would have cost him something
so he would have gotten like two and a
half points instead of three yeah yeah
very good now the shoe is on the other
foot I was fab you gonna get an
advantage with his game with the wife
predict his first move yes efore d4c for
none of the above one of the above
alright well are we going to take a
break and first of all do they
definitely will come back at 2 o'clock
we know that right from from Tony's
actually he's back earlier than 2
o'clock because they said that it would
be a 10-minute break or or two whatever
comes first
gotcha yeah this is so that means that
they'll they'll come in I see they've
ended about three or so minutes ago so I
would say that even more no more than
seven minutes
okay I didn't start the game again I
didn't know if we had a commercial break
Maryse on your board
what for you was a critical moment in
this game I think it came when Abby
played the move rook on f8 to c8
well you channel my thoughts as well
okay okay that's where I thought the
critical moment was as well in this game
because right here he showed that he
knew his stuff when he played this move
instead of playing c5 first actually
it's a sort of illogical move that
require any additional tactical nuances
because he knows is gonna play it with
protection
and there's no tactics you have to play
for is sacrificing this pawn or playing
it first and then putting the rook
behind so by playing this move you've
forced white to make a committal move
the rook leaving and going to the sea
lion weakens at a pawn so that was a
little bit of a concession for white and
what else can white do white could also
play according to the Angels move be
three maybe the most solid move as it
guards this a pawn as well and after
this move takes the knight to be for the
rookie moved to d2 the problem is after
rook to c5 White has a pure pawn
structure maybe even slightly better
coordination in fact has black pieces
are sort of randomly placed in this
position but what to make of it where do
you go your knight can't go anywhere
Knight d4 looks like a very concrete
move right but now you're running to
rook d8 and you're just pinned along the
D line rook d1 and if you make this move
that's something the bishop just does a
little ninja back step and now black is
fine and you don't have any tactics that
are real I know the engine does think
that if you keep going with a move maybe
like Bishop you maybe even f4 that's an
interesting move f4 I like this actually
continues a little bit of something
trying to guard the e5 square maybe get
your pawn pushes and hope that black can
neutralize the edge very easily
it feels cohesive that is bringing the
pieces together and harmonizing the pawn
structure with the bishop and still the
engine say triple zero but the reality
is you do have a little bit of a
position to play to at least play right
and make moves without the position
liquidating itself very quickly on the
Queen side you still have some stuff on
the board but no edge for white that
black has to be worried about
so that rook on a1 to see one move the
culprit that alone the tactical
opportunities there c5 and night before
but that was incredibly precise play by
Fabiana to neutralize what optically
looks pretty good for white well you
know why has this efore push that
usually is stronger with Queens on the
board right the endgame is not something
that black is not afraid of when you
have a pawn center right black has less
pieces on the board
so space doesn't matter as much of
course it still matters but doesn't
matter as much so this e for push looks
like a great idea but the reality of
this night before and something landing
on d3 or the tactics on a2 + c5
liquidating your position and by the way
II for might look like space temporary
temporarily when you start looking at
your bishop you're saying what's my pawn
doing on e4 right and then the point
goes to e5 after he goes to e4 then you
weaken the d5 square permanently as well
and an e5 pawn is really about attacking
right then it is trying to get space in
an endgame
so that remember we saw the game was it
my Madeira against mvl remember D Rho of
against n VL when he tried to be
aggressive with this evil u5 idea and
ended up with a bad pawn structure right
that MV l could have exploited it you
take a look at that end game where I
think what was the mistake he made NV L
played f3 instead of the move a5 which
would have been tremendous so take a
look at that game from an instructional
standpoint I think it was even the same
material distributional pieces if I was
ruling so looking but it was two rooks
Bishop and night as well against two
rooks Bishop at night if I remember
correctly anyway check that out the way
pushing pawns and getting some space
doesn't necessarily mean anything in the
endgame you can get exploited so that
was the critical moment to me I agree
with you our standing playing for here
yes we are in the playoffs for the spots
in the grand chest or final in London
yeah three place has already said
Malcolm or in first
Livan in second Maxine boss Sheila Grove
and third and finally about all the
Americans for that fourth spot the
interesting thing is no matter what the
semifinals with Nakamura
and the fourth player wielding all
American battle $300,000 in the prize
fund for the final in London including
120 pay for first place
and a minimum of 40 days for qualifying
so a lot of state curios and also just
this wonderful title of being the
Grantchester champions very very
prestigious indeed and that's what it's
all about to that then it has a very
nice payday three hundred thousand
dollars in prizes so the winner of this
match is guaranteed 40,000 but more
importantly a trip to London where the
potential is for a hundred and twenty
thousand that's our first game we are at
a standstill a draw but Viviano with the
white pieces I think he's gonna go hard
guys cuz he knows this is a clear shot
finish it it's been an exhausting few
weeks here in st. Louis and I think the
plus side of getting white in the second
game is you know you have this chance to
just get it done without giving them a
chance to be like super wild with the
black piece is so wisely tried his best
with white didn't work out
now it's 5:00 Eastern that's exactly
what it is and again if that game is a
draw then we're gonna go to the Blitz
games and they'll pair up for at least
three pairs of blitz games to try to
decide the fourth place position the
playoff that's right and I I think that
Bobby is gonna very aggressively in this
game really you're feeling what do you
think he's going for yeah then you got a
deal with the purlins yeah that's true
you mean it's hard to get aggressive
after a for unless you play something
crazy like a gambit the Kings gambit a
scotch opening actually not that
aggressive right I mean it's being tamed
right
and what if Wesley actually did
something really crazy and played the
Petroff against the backdrop against a
savvy
yeah the way we should note that
although Fabiano is not known as a bliss
rush listen I just looked up the live
rankings he's number 19 in the world in
blitz and Wesley Wesley is not known as
a blitz
specialist either was Lee's rapid reign
hasn't met number three in the world
whoo
three behind only Carlson and Nakamura
so he's number three in the world we
have Bobby at number 12 in the world in
rapid and rapid but in blitz although
far B's number 19 in the world Wesley is
only number 17 in the world they're very
close so it's not as though Bobby loses
it only draws this and thinks oh my god
I'm going it's a speed demon right now
nobody going to get someone who's fairly
is equal you know I think he's confident
that it'll be fine in the blitz
yeah and I think it particularly in the
case of Bobby shows a lot of range in
blitz you can play really really badly
especially if he gets off to a bad start
where you can play absolutely
brilliantly like we saw last year in the
showdown against Grisha so I'm sure he
assumes that it's gonna be the good
fight but we see the bad copy a lot yeah
but we'll contrast that with Wesley who
always seems to me to be the guy on an
even keel he always seems to play
consistently good he doesn't really in
the in the events 81 in Luton in Leuven
he won it was good in Paris it was
excuse me he was great in rapid right I
mean great good point I know what he was
I'm not great in blitz right and those
guys hunted him down quickly Nakamura
car yakin they came after him all guns
blazing and then that really bit him in
Paris where again he was great in rapid
and they just overtook him like
thoroughbreds and not play well at all
and then we went came here to st. Louis
and he didn't show anything here either
so the Blitz don't override his blitz
that's why he's number 17 if he were a
bit better in blitz he would have won
both Levin and Paris but he couldn't
keep that lead and also by the way and
he also lost that lead against Magnus
was it last year's look
he also lost his rapid lead Magnus to
caught him on the first day and then ran
away with it so Wesley has not shown any
great powers in blitz other than that
one no but the bottom line is are both
phenomenal and we're gonna take a few
minute break and we'll be back for the
second game absolutely
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience st. Louis University
celebrating its 200th anniversary
offering world-class education in the
heart of st. Louis Slough attracts
students and professors from around the
globe in 2015
SLU partner with the st. Louis chess
club to start a top-tier collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
team's inception Slough obtained second
best university at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the grand
chests were playoffs for the fourth
coveted spot to the final in London and
as we see the first name was a draw
between Fabiano Carolina and Wesley so
Olympic teammates as well as rivals now
for that fourth spot where the winner is
going to play against another American
Olympic team a Hikaru Nakamura in London
in the semi-finals and there you have
the first draw you said and Jennifer
it's all about aggression and you want
fabbi to bring you you're all about e to
e for something with e to e for how he
plays this there's so many aggressive
lines way against enemies oh I was told
by the way that g3 tanam there was an
override of the brake at the brake
instead of giving ten minutes they said
let's just keep it at two and keep it
clean and start at the top of the hour
instead of the ten minute break so
that's why they took a little bit longer
break than we anticipated and you'll
recall that amazing game where Fabiano
care Castle queenside not on this game
Wow the players are really blitzing them
I mean remember it's a 25-minute game
guys and doesn't this look familiar
slightly this is a difficult opening to
me yeah c2 Knight to d5 and Queen to c2
well remember this was the where Wesley
had put his knight on a three in that
previous game fairly quickly Bishop
Bishop b4 to e7 anything you can do I
can do better that's what's favi is pain
- Wesley right now exactly I think this
is the kind of position that Fabiana
wants to see though something sharp
something that could maintain some space
lots of pieces on the board Bishop to d7
played now by black
it's about the seafloor upon two is Faby
going to play a variation with E 4 and
basically say I'm not going to try to
win this pawn back or is it going to
play in a Catalan kind of style with 95
but the move Bishop d7 who want to say
he did it I also said we want to see e4
because that's just flavorful as they're
bored my lord just went on the fritz
after that kind of war clunking it down
attacking that Knight willingly giving
the chance for block to maintain that
pawn on c4 for sometime if he now plays
the move at night from deed the knight
as being attacked right now places to be
for chasing the Queen he can then
transit it to the d3 square in the heart
of White's position I can show you that
line here after E for the possibility of
Knight to be for Queen e2 and night to
d3 we were talking about nights being
entrenched in the position this is not
one of those as this night can be booted
moves like b3 could happen challenging
this Knight but it's still there and
trying to create some hay for the moment
at least
so we'll see what Wesley does in the
actual game as he still has not moved
efore is definitely throwing down the
gauntlet let's go we're trying to win in
this round
no blitz for you whoa Queen to d2 not
Queen DD at Queen d2 from favi so what's
the deal here yes after 93 what is the
difference of having the Queen on d2
because I was actually gonna say Queen
when you to then play Bishop Bishop e3
to greedily hold on to all the bishops
but maybe he wants to play for Bishop f1
wait guys only have the wrong board
position alright that's the wrong board
position he used the other thing to be
right there's a knight that's currently
hanging on d5 so a sharper he 1ups Bobby
Bobby played this very sharp E for and
he said oh no abused
other night so Queen d2 was played for a
reason because he always had this Knight
c3 out of it and then putting his knight
on d3 and if he cements all of that then
white will have some difficulty okay now
is that after Knight takes on three we
have a choice and we can take with the
Queen because now if the knight comes to
d3 we can rescue our bishop or just
capture our pawn back and then we're
kind of at that's correct that's why the
d2 I got you okay yeah we definitely
played the wrong went natural yeah the
other night but he he played this move
and kudos to Fabi as he surprised Wesley
it looks like by playing this move Queen
d2 which normally you don't play because
you're blocking that Bishop on c1 from
coming into the game it's that diagonal
but it's very specific Fabia understood
he needs to guard that night with his
queen so he could play Queen takes on c3
and it looks like Wesley did not expect
that greedy and play Knight b6 guys no
Knight takes c3 acquiescing into giving
up the c4 upon different he was planning
he wasn't you were gonna I wasn't gonna
lose his pawn anyway yeah there are two
ways of right I can defend the pawn on
d5 with so many ways to be in overspin
so only a few ways to be forgot and that
disease was play 295 nicely reward he
likes your greedy approach which was to
play Knight to b6 defending the pawn and
again with the 10 second delay nobody's
using it no one is coming that's another
way to recoup the pond although I'm not
sure if he really cares about taking the
phone immediately what do you think yes
mmm well 95 the benefit is in my view is
you're just playing to prevent Knight 2
d 3 so how about Bishop f6 also also
there's the hit on the d7 bishop that
you know you release this diagonal as
well so that you can push your pawn up
to e5 and get your Bishop in with some
action so there's there's not really
six takes e5 that's a tempo opening up
for your bishop the bishop but didn't we
see this in the game between Shak
mammy darauf was white and Abby was
black where they got a position
I don't know similar to this fabbi got
the d5 square and weak pawns but that
game ended in a hard-fought draw and I
think they'll come and we did see Fabi
thinking with this move Knight to e5
well the very greedy is just to boot the
knight right away right just okay
challenge the knight and say where are
you going
if you go back well why did you play 95
and it takes takes and at the moment the
black is holding on to his extra pawn
there are issues potential issues with
Bishop h3 and d5 seems too artificial to
you I'm not sure you you could now go
into those lines where you know the
Queen would have been on e to the knight
would have been on d3 oops sorry I'm
trying to grab the bishop so you're
trying to play Bishop e3 so that I can
be free right that's exactly what I was
thinking so a couple of very important
choices
I like the bishop six-line better though
because it seems more greed is he's a
good strategy trying to go for the
winning just avoid blitz good get to
London right absolutely he's got that on
his mind as well right and Maurice when
we were on our break we were talking
about the very very small differences of
the rating of the players in blitz but
which was just fractured three points
but in rapid that was where we saw an
edge some solid assadist 50-plus points
in rapid for Wesleyan Rock
yes for Wesley Wesley has shown himself
and perform extraordinarily well in
rapid and he just played ninety-six and
instantly Fabiano took on c6 just with
just no thought it's just amazing
he already knew this is what he wanted
to do and after Bishop takes he's moved
his Queen to c2 and all the dynamics in
this position threats of d5 may be
possible so just preparing to bring his
Bishop out and yes you're up upon but
this night on b6 yes you're up this
night is very unsafe well I should say
unhappy even this night sitting here
because it's all about guarding the pawn
and White has no interest in getting
this pawn back wise gonna try to grate
some energy on this side of the board
f4 looks a little bit too ambitious but
he'll be able to bring his pieces out
and say yes you're up the palm but
you're just gonna leave this over here
and I'm gonna use all my pieces to see
what I can do on this side of the board
so your sharp sharp play here for an
intuitive play whose clock look at the
clocks you're the person in rapid that's
so good look at the clock times five
minutes after Queen c2 and f5 super
sharp move whoa reading fire with force
higher yeah but is it weakening does it
weaken squares in blacks position so we
got a five square looks instantly a four
that night because it would be woefully
voided of squares after a five Knight
moves then d5 a critical engine the
point of a the point of f5 is to grab
that d5 square for the knight we talked
about that night name his place he's
trying to grab the square for the knight
with this move but why do thank for help
after 85 it really begs the question
right a4 now a5 well you better be ready
for something like d5 happening right
right yep I don't know what's going on
in Colossians I was wondering how the a
for a fight he took immediately on on
this square he immediately took me for
thinking about what you were saying
worries
now how a fight can be met by 95 I play
if I've anyway just just feels like
naturally low aren't you driving the
night to a stronger square night takes
I'm not that anxious to force the trade
of my light square bishop is this pawn
sacrifice justified Maurice it's
possible but the move a five will happen
in that position and you can play a five
instead actually engines don't like this
at all because of the response a five by
black now the sort of timing is an issue
it looks like the correct move is to
play a five in this moment after a four
Fe for play a five ninety five and then
Knight takes on e4 and now this pawn has
been isolated this pawn and you'll win
it back now whether or not you have an
edge here I used to play and the French
the exchange French and Joe Benjamin
grandmasters Oh Benjamin who you know
very well yeah sure in a colleague for
so many decades he showed me that even
though he had a week six pawn the
isolated D pawn was a problem when he
gets blockaded and that these weaknesses
balanced each other out if Black gets
enough dynamism so what I see this I
remember the spanking he gave me in a
lesson in this line so but this is a
slightly different position on a very
different position because I got it out
of an exchange French and it didn't have
a fee and Kaye told Bishop but probably
could win his pawn back it looks like
eventually in this position and then
look to see if he could get something
going on this line as well so this will
be double edged a big decision for him
right now to play the move a5 or to take
on e4 immediately and it looks like he's
investing the time in the position to
try to figure out which one should he do
as he has a really nice edge on the
clock right now five minutes just passed
he used to have five minutes little
under five minutes right now big
decision in the game drive the knight to
the middle that feels counterintuitive
or to take on e4 and he's taking with a
bishop money for a third choice in the
position and here we go well he's
hitting the pawn on h7 which suggests
that black should
sure and I am I'm reading the tea leaves
correctly
fabbi is planning to recapture on e4
with this Queen and I ball two pawns the
e6 and b7 point won't have time for that
a5 so I'm just equal eyes the pawns now
with Queen takes b7 well the structure
is bad for everybody those paws are so
separated on both sides the C pawns are
doubled
certainly the e pawn is weak White has
an isolated a deep on a backward be pawn
on an open file no less d5 you have to
reckon with the reply of Bishop c5 as we
did use the D Brooke - we use the effort
to play d1 so f2 could become a
potential weakness
it's juicy-looking defied when you've
got a reckon with Bishop c5 right your
your again for sure yeah that could
really chill the attacking ambitions in
a big way we're going out also Queen d7
on your board Queen d7 to exp seven the
move rook a b8 is yeah a very sneaky
don't go pawn grabbing on a 7 because
letting your Queen get out of there
because you could find yourself in a
world of her with that move also Knight
d5 was a strong move as well clearing
the open file for the rook and preparing
some trappy business with that Queen as
two rooks prepare to go a and B against
the Queen yeah I think I have to repeat
I'd have to withdraw the Queen Maurice
but now 9595 and you've got your room
you've got everything
no I see no danger here that C pawn
acting as a restraining force in Queen B
7 was Wesley's choice definitely and I
don't I think Bobbie probably saw this
far and thought this was good and now
realizes that this is not that great for
life you should have played sharper with
a 5 and this line I didn't like
Bishop usually war was not grain feel
like it had enough snap crackle and pop
initiative Bishop before I'm flowing if
you take some play Queen takes I'm
flowing and now that he's gotten here
he's looking at it and saying wait I
don't really care about the b7 points
usually we don't care about those kind
of pawns trying to get into the position
and giving the opponent a chance to make
a couple of moves and get some dynamic
play
you're not even winning upon when you
take on B second you're just restoring
material quality definitely not worth it
so I think he played that Bishop b4 move
in haste thinking that it would be a
good idea and now he's regretting it as
he's got to look for moves well blacks
hyper solid everywhere and I don't see I
suspect he's not taking on visa and as
Jennifer mentioned when you play a move
like d5 which is ultra aggressive you're
you're dreaming of all kinds of
initiatives you got to be very very
mindful very very mindful that that rook
is suddenly a potent attacker on the F
line so d5 does I feel like suddenly
favi better start thinking equality in
this position that's a liquidating move
ya know that's basically saying look I'm
kind of looking to make equality out of
this mess you got it I've got a memo
that dude was not right Bishop a4 was a
real error for white in fact the third
move we mentioned but it did not it did
too much in terms of going after the
attack allowing the liquidation and
black just absorb the energy and said go
right ahead I'm gonna get more than you
are as you try to grab your pawn and how
does this liquidate everything because
it is a pawn right yes
take one d5 is black and can you show me
the line well I'm just I'm actually
thinking this three moves Jim I'm
thinking Bishop c5 is a move I'm
thinking rook on a a to d8 a move and
I'm thinking about liquidation as well
yes Knight takes d5 very very quickly
played and he's hoping to trade off nice
and then take the C pawn
so let's just go with the line Knight
takes d5 rook 65 Queen c6 don't take my
bishop don't take my bishop the rook is
the the rook needs protection
Princeton's liquidating that that pawn
going to be in serious trouble
well never mind that I'm thinking I'll
put my bishop on the long diagonal I'll
take the pawn on b2 and then I'll play
see it's a it's a passer by the way
takes d5 is on the board as Wesley
decides where to put his queen but I
think Queen six is super suggestive I
think rookie fights an excellent move to
try to bail out I'm not a hundred
percent sure you do get away unscathed
oh sorry that's a check I have to be
watchful I was thinking that you would
take I'd have the old swimsuit no I
think rookie five is an excellent
attempt to bail out and say okay he's
played rook d4 somewhat 64 you're
renewing the threat of Queen 67 and
let's see Bishop c5 enjoy 166 route
takes e4 you might want to watch out
it takes up two or it's okay just came
g2 and and there's gonna be a
liquidation well but it's an extra pawn
still so black Bishop a4 Bishop f4
doesn't quite do the trick do the trick
yet because you have this in between
moves Bishop d4 hitting me on b2 and
watch out
it's a snot and you have no better than
what you just did by the I was thinking
rookie you know the nitesite may be a
rookie five is better because rook d4
drive-e for Bishop c5 what exactly is
Fabi doing to earn material equality
it looks like Queen c6 is box forced
it's been played
I mean question six now you mean for
white sorry we have six yes B takes c6
now you could
pause and play rope f4 but then I'll
play Ruby 8 so let's just look at this
line again it still looks like Black has
the pull we just got this is the current
position Wesley so to play we're
anticipating Bishop c5 as our main line
[Music]
but it's very easy for black to play his
next moves are Bishop d4 threatening
rook F to look on the AAA to b8 and you
want to call it a half upon its my I
just what you look at your this position
yeah it's such a deep move to find and
Bishop c5 is about to land on the board
it looks like you know it there we go
there's a deep move in this position I
see an onion board I guess I wanted to
challenge you to find it yeah problem up
F to the problem of a bishop D force you
want to play b4 but you got this work
have to check coming so how do you guard
against all of that you play the amazing
rook to a2 threatening B for threatening
before attacking that Bishop on f2
guarding that square as well so a bishop
d4 lands now you can play b4 suddenly
you have there's the lateral protection
on the F 2 square
there's no hit to the rook on a1 and
you're threatening the pawn on c5
undermining the bishop on d4 all at once
that's the engine did point this out and
we'll see whether or not Bobby finds
this sequence because that's a very
beautiful defensive move that's the kind
of way you could put in a book on
defensive moves what do you play now as
white and that kind of move to find it's
not a sexy mating 3 where you sack your
queen but that's the kind of move that
the top players will find and say this
is why we're super GX well this is what
we've been talking about throughout the
sinkhole Cup the extraordinary defensive
techniques of the players and moves like
rook a to the computer will be training
them to find that unusual
move and that doesn't look like it will
give equality know that Bobby hasn't
played very quickly though it's not
clear that he sees it yet
well rook a to is a hidden defensive gem
let's be clear
not so fast all-star move it takes on c4
allows mixture of two and he might be
starting to look at the position he
might have evaluated it correctly that's
fine for himself but hasn't actually
found the moves to justify that he's
just as positional intuition says you
know that CC pawn I'm just dropping F to
no big deal be able to find him in fact
he might have even seen the Bishop f4
move and thought that saw the problem in
ridership and then only after looking at
the move Bishop d4 is he going
wait this is harder than I thought right
he may have felt like Jennifer that
Bishop f4 what's the problem
everything's copasetic but until you see
Bishop d4 rook the rook e8 and now
looking at in he has played rook takes
e4 and the players are speeding up to
this critical position will after the
move c-65 will fabbi play rook a find
rook a to because that is that's just a
beautiful defensive Bobby looks so much
the mystery is about to be solved you
better find rook to a2 magnificent move
just another level as it resolves all
his problems in one move rotate soo and
is the only move by the way that does
that everybody now eyes everything else
is worse for white which shows that it
came into this vine intuitively he did
not see rotate to in advance he came
into this line intuitively feeling that
he should be okay and it's now that he
understands this is a critical moment in
the game talk about knowing when
critical moments arise and be able to
judge that I need to think right now so
that the guy doesn't get anything this
is the moment for him to look and see if
he can find something and his spidey
sense is telling him this is how this is
right now I don't want to play a bad
move because black is suddenly up upon
with the move Bishop d4 that [ __ ] is
going to be a beast rook f2 coming in
all the real coming to the beeline can't
develop your bishop
I need a move and you see he's looking
furiously right now trying to figure out
what's the answer yeah this was a very
beautiful quote by Boris Spassky much
like to the players of today the world
champion was somehow just a little bit
ahead of his peers and Boris was asked
what made him better than his peers and
he said the only advantage I have over
my colleagues is I have an incredible
intuition about the critical moments I
use my time during the critical moments
and my opponents sometimes just fritter
away time in positions that are not key
this is a key moment if fabulet finds
rook a to which is a very difficult
unusual defensive resource you know you
just got to tip your hat say these guys
are really good but it is the kind of
move that says that's extra that's just
amazing written all over it
right and it looks yeah yeah this is the
critical moment this is key I don't
think he sees it even now I think it's
the kind of thing you're looking and
looking and your brain is going Circle
Circle and then when you find it you go
that's it I think you just play but he
feels it you could tell the feeling is
there there's something just screaming
somewhere in the depths recesses of his
mind something is here right now I have
to find a movie you see how much time
he's invested to find this kind of move
that and also by the way when you look
at moves with an engine you know we're
sitting back you're at home you're
looking at it and you see the mover k2
you think okay that's all the problems
you will not see that move if I take the
engine away from you exact that's a
hidden gem in the position those are
moves that even super GM's find very
difficult to see you just won't see
hidden those like especially the
discovery on the f2 square that's why
you sometimes want to look at chess
especially these type games without an
engine when you're watching major events
absolutely
using an engine is after you've played a
game you've sweated it out and then
afterwards you can compare especially if
you don't have a few years whether the
sacrifice would have worked but I mean
from this position every every training
that you may have put yourself under it
would would tell you develop your bishop
get your pieces out win back the pawn
bishop and open up it's incredible right
because he had done it yet
yeah would you might think let me play
Bishop f4 and think about the next move
you play Bishop f4 in a bullet game
without any noise just the right right
just look like the right move right okay
so deep gets off the long diamond yes
and potentially attacks f2 indeed yes
controls that Square and um prepares to
play before developing the bishop
potentially in a different way but yes
when to think hard this is actually a
topic of my TEDx talk and it's it's
insane that as soon as you said that you
called it that Fabi is sinking into a
deep thought yay his spidey sense is
saying oh oh there's some real danger in
this position I have to be careful I
need a really good move Bishop f4 you
play in bullet game but he's saying
after Bishop f4 Bishop d4 I'm clearly
worse I'm not gonna try to save that
ending where's my move where's my move
and again you're absolutely white when
you're sitting there at home with an
engine and it's informing you rook a to
zero zero zero you think okay why that's
easy that's easy no no III don't agree
with that only about unseen the moves I
also think that that people who work
with engines have to know what
moves look like yes right I can see the
move okay - it solves all the problems
sure but I know what a hard move looks
like yeah rook a - is not the kind of
move you want to play it's not natural
at all so you know yeah so the engine is
just giving us this answer but boy if I
was sitting in this position trying to
find Roque to myself are you crazy
that's a deep move I would not be
looking in that direction only after I
calculated Bishop a4 worked out all the
variations and then start to wonder is
there something I feel desperate
what can I do you might start looking at
all the moves you don't find this move
even after a long think and Froggy's
been added now that's just in this
position don't forget he spent some time
even before he got to this position six
minutes and even before he played those
couple of exchanges to get to this
position he was aware there was a
position coming up and here he is and
boy hard at work and we see there he's
reaching for the queenside one of them
is going to be the bishop or the rook
and I don't think he sees it otherwise
work he too would have been on the board
already I think you're right okay big
applause Bravo that is that's
world-class rookie - in that position
amazing solving all the problems in one
go leaning back now is Fabi as Wesley's
looking at this one I don't know if once
they've seen it but he's going
shutting down everything in one go
fantastic move Wow
I mean what well you got to imagine
Wesley sitting there and reeling back
and he's thinking I am upon up or I'm
gonna torture you for some time let's
see what you got
[Music]
Oh No okay just give me an extra pawn to
work with I'm not asking for much let's
just enjoy that video again because we
were worried he was reaching for his
Bishop Jennifer he's doing something on
the queenside yeah if you go breaking
quickly you know you miss me also tell
you there's you ever I told you about my
my friend Leon how he we had that one
exercise where you know me the boat he
played a game and he said where where's
the mistake he just played over a game
and we went through it and then when you
played this move f5 it was so int
positional looking at sit and this was a
between masters all right maybe the GM
this move was hyper aggressive and I
looked and I said oh that's the moment
and he's like and he smiled because I
had guessed it right
when I go over games a lot of times
you'll go over a game it's so boring
it's like oh it's all the stuff we've
seen yeah yeah okay and even they soccer
pieces like oh yeah you sucked and
there's a win ever pause who cares but I
relish those moments when somebody plays
they're moving you even if you're going
over fast and you go way what what's
this one without and that mover okay two
will be one of those moments I'll be
going over the game my editor Oh what's
what's this why did you have to play
this move and then when you started
looking at because it's so unusual
looking you started looking at it and
you go wow what if you tried something
else and you realize this move is deep
and it's the one move you just put in
your file just record this I want to
have this and especially for my students
yes
what would you do right here those are
the things you the Nuggets you look for
and just like I say gives you those
goosebumps you're a good feeling that
you just learn something in a moment and
that rook a to is one of those moves
that sets these guys apart somebody like
Fabi trying to become the champion of
the world has to find most like that and
invest at this time and you
see the effect its had as well on Wesley
you know that it's funny the contrast
between these rook moves that we've got
so excited about rook takes f7 by Levon
yesterday oh yeah I suppose the short is
just as sweet in my opinion if you were
to find these kinds of creepy crawly
moves weird position threatened to disco
everything just because again our
training that we teach our students as
well as ourselves develop your pieces
bring your you know control the center
even if you had played a move like rook
on a2 to a3 on the previous move you
could explain that to yourself you could
justify it your pawn on b2 is weak your
rook on a1 is passive
you know bring your rook up make it
aggressive centralize your rook but this
move rook a to is so contrary to so much
about it and it's the perfect it fits so
well you've got to cover f2 the second
rank you you're waiting that when the
bishop does retreat to d4 you have the
move b4 under undermining the anchor or
the support of the bishop your rook is
not under attack when the bishop
retreats it's like all the boxes get
everything you don't feel any danger
anymore look at Bobby he's leaned back
and if Wesley had seen the move you
didn't ever reply to it because he's now
tanked for exactly about five minutes on
the clock right that's the effect of
moves like that it feels like somebody
just drove to the hole and dumped on you
the fans are cheering and you're like oh
my goodness what am I supposed to do as
his time is ticking down this could even
turn the game around it's going to get a
game changer let's make a suggestion
even though it's equal by the way yeah
this is the kind of move that could have
an effect psychologically okay
I'm in Wesley shoes I'm rock back oh
he's played the move Bishop d4 just was
yeah just just when I was about to say
I'll try to turn the rook against itself
I was thinking about the move Bishop in
one with the idea of rook F - in case
you capture my pawn and I try to make
the look rook look silly on a - but that
wasn't played Bishop before
and then of course the plan to be for
disrupting me very very immediately not
even using the delay by the way and that
is I think that's a characteristic of a
lot of really strong players is that
they go for deep link and then sometimes
instant moves after it yeah yeah they've
got their moves all prepared they're
ready to counter whatever their opponent
what a confidence right confidence to
know what a moment is the thing hard but
then also the confidence to just not
rechecking your analysis because you've
been checking in on your opponents time
indeed okay idea and was he still fine
that's not of course of course was a
defensive move right not a winning move
but it was a brilliant defense it was
genius of course his seven-minute tank
was replied to with a tank of weslee
zones all right the big question for me
is are they gonna get into big-time
pressure in this game or are we gonna
see liquidation and blitz thereafter
what do you think yeah yeah well that
your Malinsky wrote could you tell me
that yeah modern chess your molinsky
wrote a great book I loved it yes and he
wrote this great book and his point yeah
he talks about the trends in positions
he talks about how do you respond when
the road that's right that's right and
he talks about how do you respond when
things go up down stay the same Wow
how are you feeling when you have a
great position and suddenly that changes
right what is your psychological
response to that not just the the
reality objective reality of the moves
on the chessboard how do you react
personally and Wesley have this position
where he has to feel very positive he
was forward-thinking Zac I'm gonna get
this guy I'm coming after him and then
probably plays rook a to and he is
pushed back and suddenly he realizes
wool I don't have and he might keep
searching where is the advantage where
is it where's my avenging you find out
there is no advantage now how do you
clean out your entire system and say
okay I got it it's equal and just be
told
flatline Bobby has that amazing ability
anchoring the bishop because he lost the
c5 anchor and now he's just planning to
gang up on this pawn yes
yeah I think he played 76 but he's ready
to play trick d5 work at five and gang
up on the suit on well let's see how it
might go well that part is easy to the
bishop after the or rook d5 Bishop to d6
talk about anchors Anchors Away rook f5
so everybody's trained here and guess
what everybody's trained here too
actually it's a could I play rope to d2
yes exactly I would have to yes I can't
take the pawn because you would trade my
rook and then capture the bishop but I'd
have to move the bishop right so I'm not
worried about dropping my pawn and right
in such a position before is on the
board Bishop f4 is on the board okay and
Wesley put his work on d8 for a reason
and I think you're right also I thought
it was a rookie yes you did
yeah well well he did it with the idea
of playing with d5 and and chasing the
c5 home sorry Mary's I saw another
equalizing line with rookie two moving
you saw another equalizing line here
continue the game no okay game just take
this rookie fibre rookie to here rook e
to so you're basically saying I'm not
worried take my pawn I've got I've got
counter play downstairs and can actually
you still can't touch my bond why is
that
oh you could touch an innocent my rook
check oh I see you're gonna you're gonna
get me from behind that's what I was
hoping
there's no but the engine saying is
equal here okay five aren't you losing a
piece straight maybe it says this ship
takes d6 and my engine
[Laughter]
- and if you take my pawn yeah my engine
says okay why is it still a draw why is
it still played a different movie five
he's not what his working on eh
so he's basically giving up any attempts
he may have been entertained about
winning that pawn on c5 and engines
don't like this move to rook to d2 and
this this is starting this is the point
we made how would you respond when you
have been rocked back would you find the
right moves the accurate moves in each
and every position and may I point out
look at the clock times eleven twenty
six for Fabi you see Wesley moved those
chess pieces just now that's a little
bit of an irritation it's it's a towel
wait if it's out I know that towel well
you're uncomfortable yeah your time
sticking down you need things out your
way right and even if it's not even that
close you feel the pressure of those
pieces that you captured you said let's
just move this even further out of my
way you might even throw it only players
know that feeling of the pieces
bothering you even though they're not
that close push them out the way yeah I
I saw that my my understanding there was
nervousness nervousness was creeping in
and now Rudi sixes it's a nice move I
love well I mean that pawn on c5 that a
moment ago we thought he was gonna try
to build up an attack against the part
on the South I think now it's well yeah
that's a good leverage there he's using
that c5 pawn as an anchor because you
never want to take on
gorgeous d6 we double time on the glass
okay honey
complete change the initiative shift Wow
Wow look at that clock ticked I remember
he was down on time yeah at that
12-minute mark 214 and since then nine
minutes by Wesley to his one and a half
minutes that rotates who had that effect
and just simply so far has been a
game-changer Wesley better start finding
some moves yeah not a big fan of it but
sometimes you do and I'm not there's no
circumstances trading route 66 and
allowing a passed pawn as powerful so I
think you're right I think I think the
good news is that you're right that
there should be seven but it's not you
know in such positions sometimes you
just let your opponent hang themselves a
move like a five looking for another
potential anchor or h4 is a variable
here's the problem with the if you just
go for it right away
oh you a lot of guy said yeah he is
ready with his defensive move squeeze
cha yeah exactly just improve the
position and also allow on a check allow
your H point not to hang on any checks
on e to the King just waltzes it but
there this guy's boss hey this guy's
lost he's finding some serious level
moves H for stopping any g5 anything
maybe push the pawn down the board make
you play a move like eight six and if
you do
I snap it with the bishop bishop takes
86 will be taught hh-hi on the board
that's a little tiny weakness White's
king is definitely going to be closer to
the H pawn right it's kind of stuck
because we can't play with d4 we can't
play it before that easily even king of
three was looking for ideas that's why I
was reaching for the King but and again
I'm kind I'm leaning towards your rook
before Bishop e7 yeah yeah just just let
me just show a little bit of why it
might be attracted to this remember the
game between Sergey and Sergey and
magnets magnets are gay Magnus - yeah
Magnus sacrificed in exchange for a pawn
and a bishop and such ideas do get my
attention but it's not just because
there's a logical move it's because your
head on the clock yeah and you can if
you can improve the position and allow
your opponent to erode his because he
doesn't have a great position sitting in
front of them now he might find some
good moves in response great defense but
he's under five minutes
don't get near him on the clock that's
key keep the lead make a quick move if
you're looking for a knockout blow you
could invest a lot of time on the clock
and it's not the position for the
knockout blow that's the problem he's
looking for it and he might now be in
reinvesting time at a moment that's not
critical Maurice you just mentioned a
really important point and one of the
most difficult points for grandmasters
when do you invest your time looking for
a knockout blow right like wow nobody
taps you on your shoulder it says now's
the combinations now the combination I
start looking for knockout blows
whenever I feel that my pieces are more
that I have an advantage that I can
absolutely understand and justify so
that's why I'm thinking rook before
Bishop e7 would be seven if you don't
take my rook you know I'm I'm getting
close to a knockout blow and King that
he had to he he had to stop himself and
he says is there something there let me
just double check because I love that
rook on d6 is there something there and
rook e1
Wow okay
with this move rook e1 I am imagining
that black is starting to think okay
your king's a little bit vulnerable
can i play moves like rook b8 and rook
b3 check sacrificing upon but is it
really for what you wanted to do when
you play this is definitely did because
I want all my pieces to be more active
than all of yours right at the right
moment if you have enough activity true
to then either force the favorable
bishop trade or sticker work on these
ovens okay so let me give you a check
and put my rook on I don't know a decent
Square and work these and rook d7 by the
way look yes a played so rook rook d7
now I still like or feels very so Marian
oh every move is pretty just into my
dengue technique precision this guy
they're not all my moves I got the help
of the engine do a couple of moves that
I've seen myself write most of them in
the inches work a2 was not my move that
was an engine move so let's not get that
twisted right right now the move rookie
the moves that he's playing it just
raises the picture of perfection in a
rapid remind you of madness really you
mentioned that totally yours darkness
playing an in game that's pretty equal
and just seeing what happens well I
really didn't like didn't we say he's
got to show what he can do in rapper
yeah that's what we said he's got a show
when I play rapid chess I could play
like the genius the way Magnus shows all
the time you play most like rookie two
against Magnus you're gonna be okay but
you got to find all those moves cuz he's
gonna test you right in those situations
but if he can start showing this level
of play beautiful technique consistent
then we can say fabi's ready he's ready
now I'm showing his stuff and he's ready
for the World Championship he feels this
pressure look at this well what's Lee
understands if he trades ROK's inviting
White's King into the center of the
board there's this King f5 came g6 when
things get really really dicey around
blacks King what is what is this line
guys are we looking at something like
this as a line of play I mean it's a you
have to look at the forcing moves in
such a situation I won't mention any
names but that move rook d7 stopped me
from playing my desired be eight I don't
like blacks position right but that was
what the book on B wine he's now on a
one we're stopping
it's tethered for a moment I better buy
a pond I'm not playing were k-8 so let's
play a five and if it's attacked are you
playing okay seven yep
brookey attack it what else we don't
need a second he was like 55 I'm
thinking about Bishop e5 27 on the board
rook d7 I'm just thinking about this
ship ye5 probably this double rook
ending my king is a little bit too
exposed so but that Bishop on it
answered by a check testing him testing
him right now I think that was a good
check this King kind of bothered me as a
potential attacker so driving the King
back is a good idea for black man's late
and it's back to that a pawn again okay
well if I have to play a six and or a
five and rook a seven I mean I've got to
get some kind of plate three you just
thinking with with the ricky seven right
although you're packing anything a seven
and Bishop c3 c3 so Ricky seven at the
moment
oh no there's no threat though five what
about Bishop e5 sorry in this exact
moment
Bishop e5 threats to take on g7 which
okay okay and if you do I'm going to be
hitting the world yeah do I get wait do
I get some kind of place no but I'm
gonna I'm gonna win your G or you're
gonna be able to win maybe I take on h5
yeah it's messy anyway he played Bishop
d6 instead more control chess after rook
d7 did we see the move a five we did Oh
saw a five yeah I got a six I can take
on a six and hitting your c6 so I'm
gonna take too long Hey
I love this King h7 those types of moves
that Bishop on d6 is very impressive
well it's also in the way a little bit
to tell you the truth but it's about the
clock now and keeping the pressure on
with the clock as an issue and now rook
to 1/7 attacking the pawn by the way
they could be some rookie six tempo on
your bishop in the future that you have
to watch out for century on the boris
III but isn't it similar to what we just
looked at except now each right is
hanging with check right absolutely
so that seems even worse but now I'm
worried about the pin actually what
happens there Bishop e5 no no Bishop e5
rook e8 could I see that quickly should
be fine and if I play rookie a rookie a
designer blunder because rook g7 check
but now I can go to 86 and you're
defended but now we trade everything off
for people of your evil on and I'll
picked up the C pawn that in game okay
all right so Bishop c3 Bishop e5 very
legit looking loo looking at the clocks
four minutes for five e two minutes four
and he's played King h3 by the way but
the immediate rook e3 while it pins
I have rook check is a way of escaping
the pin King age 3 makes such ideas as
rookie 3 quite okay - he was afraid of
that pin but also watch out for your
king mating ideas in there if you got to
watch out for it oh you mean like if I
could do something like roar oh I heard
about root no I was a rook so up with
that mating idea me but but you just
pointed out that move oh it's all that's
happened
okay - there's no hobbies on move going
to three-and-a-half I'm sorry I'm seeing
your monitor there he's feeling that
King got a little bit squeezing he
doesn't have an easy move and now Bishop
e5 is still on top but but what about
that move rookie EE three Maresa or by
the way about even rooks e4 is a
consideration the bishop the bishops
tethered to the aid no reasons I'm just
looking for something a little bit more
nasty I don't know Brooke c4 where would
where would black go with his bishop mmm
give me your bishop I'm dreaming that
you give up the long diagonal if you go
bishop before I want to repost my bishop
you don't want to hear this yes Oh what
if you play rosy for Bishop f6 yes a
vicious trap no no I mean I was to the
same problem rook e8 right now yes
thirty-eight that same idea I was sawing
I was worried about that King now the
rook can go down and you need to deal
with this attack suddenly on your
position he stuck out with a struck out
with look at you one okay one you made
your problem this is where Magnus would
look at the talk and go yes I got him
because you went below on the clock
Fabi has to realize this moment is
critical for him or he could lose the
game this is a trend that's varying too
much time and he has roots seen for if
Wesley finds this move Bishop wait a
minute this there's also because you see
that now but you got the bishops hang
the bishops hanging Ricky - we have g4
right not with you too but rook we've
seen Bishop before the move that I
thought every black there was wide the
move rook c4 the reason I'm attracted to
that move is because I see this bishop
floating in the air I wanted to get to
declare itself declare its diagonal
that's was a backhand
that Brooke at four now totally a
different kind of chess position as the
bishop is no longer guarding g7 and
we'll have to spend a tempo to deal with
that as Bishop e5 is under threat what
do I think he should have actually guys
okay five is very strong yeah yes
because we've got Bishop f4 if you play
teenage six yep a new g5 track is
possible you're dropping material here
that Disher before was a serious mistake
but Fabiano has now turn his brain away
from rapid chess and start getting into
blitz chess mode you must feel this as a
blitz game and he hasn't done it yet
because a blitz can you just play your
instinctive move and go and he's and
that's a skill you have to have and he
has not done it yet still looking for
some kind of clear win in fact there is
no clear when you might win a pawn but
it's not gonna be a mate so that means
you have to convert this which means
you'll need time on your clock exactly
and not a good like that not a good move
Oh guys if I work at five exactly all
that yeah well because we kept aah pawn
with check your King goes to g4 and
that's the end of the story well I was
gonna take on a four rook a five rook
takes a four give up my H pawn for the a
pawn and hope for the best
I still think that you know white is
really four choice I mean I'm not honest
I'm not sure I understand when he forced
the move Bishop before could he have
played Bishop e5 at once what played by
wisely yeah what are they played rookie
that rip David a yeah we now that now
that are basically playing a blitz we
should get under a minute play rook
air-five go but he looks like he's
scared of giving up his a pawn for his
Aggies pawn right he doesn't want to
make that trade for some reason I would
I would make that trade believing that I
can hunt down blacks King yeah trade
ropes with Bishop Bishop I mean trade
bishop so Bishop e5 right and go for it
and just take that edge but he's taking
way
too much time right now move move and go
there's nothing important now you're
again the good is the enemy or the
perfect is the enemy of the good right
now you're looking for that perfect move
and you have 20 seconds on the clock to
make good enough moves now you're not
going to survive in there
he played rookie six now they just
really hate his last move by the way
yeah I can feel the advantage slipping
away that was not someone who's after
all that was right brilliant chess
before he is not doing it now and he's
gotta have a move ready just move yeah
and look at that 20 seconds again let's
try it yeah look look at the clock 14
seconds come on this is Jerry he's about
to blow London right now finally working
fine 16 seconds to try to convert this
position when he's just not winning he's
being Eve might win a pawn but he's not
just winning this is crazy 40,000 on the
line here guys and a trip to London did
he oh thank goodness I was about to say
yeah what did that move do well now we
know it hits the bishop on c3 okay and
54 played and White's advantage is gone
let's just be clear Weiss advances no
longer well me now here's a survive
rupee for rookie for chasing the bishops
luckily bishops you one can be answered
by g4 and I might play it anyway if I'm
white just quite solid White's still why
it's okay here but you need two moves
you need to just play g4 and try to get
out of this mess did he play bishops you
want them no the bishop as many jets and
so we're playing bullet with the delay I
believe I said I play g4 ambition
g7 just okay that's the solid that's a
solid move Bishop g7 and Wesley is now
finally ready to rook which work work on
three two III III and that's actually
the engines first choice as he's still
fine he's still looking for accurate
moves in this position let's just hope
the mistake does not just flow out of
nowhere in our room 207 look at this
seven hello
now I've got a he is very turbulent
ideas rookie to protecting his position
but but is that enough well I can trade
rooks and finally get an active you
gotta watch out for Europe the
penetration for the white yeah I'd have
to go you can G anything there's a rook
c6 you mean okay okay I'm worried that
you're can king position is even worse
than mine in that line and that my pawns
a little closer so Wesley's time ticking
down as well and he's traded now
probably will get no more than 16
seconds for the rest of the game as this
delay is keeping on this spot and our
Bishop to do it for now it's time for
Wesley sis to start thinking getting as
King okay rookie for why it's supposed
to be better according to the engine
right now but it's not clear where that
better decided to temple in d4 first
probably trying to make you clarify the
clock before you notice how that piece
tripped tripped on my side on the B 5
squared in fact in fact the engine
registered it as rook to be 4 but not
rook to e7 can change the nature of the
game but I didn't see it or he didn't
see it or maybe 7 was super strong haha
don't walk into that here
and Wesley now just ticked under Fabio
though he has that +10 ideas but he
could chase that Bishop rook and he did
get it out of there and move it no make
threats rook c7 he's going after the C
pawn he thought he was going for I
thought he was gonna play King g8
instead of that Bishop she won but okay
for both odds have calmed down and I
foreshadowed earlier was he's gonna grab
that Queen f7 not quite on the square
there I was did that move even get
registered that was fast
see that C pawn he's right in c6 c7 rook
a queen really fast right now and Wesley
in trouble trying to deal with this
that's a check and if he goes backwards
he just made it if he tries to put his
King on c8 that's made king d7 c6 king
c8 rook e8 his mate made so what are you
supposed to do kb5 there goes that pawn
get that Queen ready white is now
winning so much more powerful and he's
gotten behind it but now it's firmly
defended the threat is rook to aid and
Queens heads out to stop it
you can't play Bishop e5 cuz if rook
takes a five and that's the bottom piece
it's fighting with this it's like a
rookie age you have to result there's a
3 3 if you a 3 he has - yes - wait one
tempo guys because a 3 saves him from
Queens right oh you should be - and now
here comes the Queen and he's calculated
that he is indeed winning as he's going
to be able to get his rook behind that
pawn right at least and this is going to
London twice
the world--you I mean get in men for the
grand Chester title congratulations
Fabiano
whoo beat his Olympic teammate Wesley
what would have been bought in playoff
instead that Bishop b2 Maurice what
would have happened after a three
because you mentioned a three I don't
know let me pull it up I can pull it up
okay brocade a three I think he has to
take it a the engine gives rook a five
check Kate King has to go back to e6
okay and then Wow rookie four oh I
didn't see that
Queenie with Czech hitting the six but
no cheers and applause for Fabiano Wow
managing himself is nerves in that one
whoo that was exciting and I have to
tell you this is where I prefer delay to
increment because they just had only
that time base time every time each time
each time and not to make quick moves
instead of rushing running up to a
minute plus and that was an incredibly
exciting finish on the race to London as
Khurana has made it official top four
who are going to the grand chester final
in London Hikaru Nakamura the US star
who shines so great in both the Paris
and st. Louis wrapping and glitz
tournaments he's gonna be facing his
Olympic gold teammate Fabiano Khurana in
the semifinals and we're also going to
see him in the elimination that's right
well upon running on and i'm maxeen by
sherrilyn grab headed to London two of
the most fun players on the tour as well
exactly it's just done I'm still
recovering that was heart pounding a
very deserving quartet
oh no question those guys I've played a
great grand gesture and oh I kept this
on the edge of our seats he's a gold
Olympic teammate Wesley so and here is
Fabiano terre wanna our fourth finalist
on the grand gesture well he continues
to regale us with his determination
tenacity and poise in the critical
moments and this one was one of those
Bobby this is sort of a boring game you
just play congratulations first
excellent results
winning the sink filled cup time for
first in that and also qualifying for
London an improbable comeback given our
poorly you started on the rapid and
blitz events to be able to pull it off
now must be very satisfying
yeah I'm incredibly happy especially
with how it all ended because uh after
Magnus won yesterday I for for a second
I thought that I was just out and then I
realized that it was a time that was
already a huge relief that I still have
a chance to to make it but yesterday was
sort of a rollercoaster of emotions and
and today as well you were able to
equalize that first game pretty
straightforward fashion with this second
game you had this big moment that the
engines were finding this rookie to move
which is obviously not an easy move at
any level to find everybody will
appreciate the depth of that move when
did you see it yeah I I started thinking
about this before and I'm sure [ __ ]
before I realized I'm just worse I
couldn't find a way to make me forward
because he actually just got a fin a 500
all the time and then I tried to make be
for work but then I realized he takes I
click [ __ ] before and he just plays
like a five ignoring the [ __ ] one of
two and here's this g5 this g5 move
regaining the bishop so I'm still not
equalizing there yeah rook before c5 is
also just south like Bishop a4 and a5
this is important no yeah instead of I
mean before take fish before 85 is
cementing that pawn on video and then
and then the bishop is a mean because of
g5 and black has a large advantage in
blue okay maybe it's still draw
objectively look and then I saw this
route pay to move after maybe eight
minutes of thoughts my god yeah you
wanting it for a while so it was only
near that and after I thought I almost
immediately played it right that one I
thought that's what would happen when
you see the kind of thing your brain is
running and running and running in your
desperate and then a move just says you
know and you and you play it immediately
then the game got tense I mean he wasn't
so easy even after that I thought rook
da was maybe not
yeah like lookout father should be a
draw
I assume was just an equal position well
then he allowed me route d6 and I
started to get very optimistic at least
I could keep the game going I mean I I
know it's not a huge advantage but black
is suffering especially after work c8
maybe he could make something else work
but 3060 d6 I also thought jihad Bishop
c1 and and I do keep my deep one and he
has to brotherly pawn so so he'll
probably suffer quite a lot here and I'm
the game I mean I thought I have a huge
advantage his work is just trapped on
the eighth rank but I couldn't quite
find a way to make progress there were
other ways for you to prosecute the play
apparently but we both I mean we saw you
both were in a terrific time pressure
when it really turned into blitz mode
yeah here I just didn't see what to do
so I played tried to get this work at
five and then I was just trying to keep
his work out because I really didn't
want to allow some sort of
counter-attack with it you know a long
time you might get made it so basically
all my moves at this one we're just
trying to keep his work out and and I
was very happy to get g6 there because
then I know that my King is always safe
and his King his mom and then somewhere
he offered the job but I didn't really
think about it oh he offered yeah I
forget which moment before you up on the
time we do have one time when this
happened I mean well how much was he at
one time does he know at that point we
were here we were equal in time so I
assume it was after we traded rooks yeah
some yeah after Bishop c4 he offered to
drop this was a moment but I I don't see
any risk for me and I still saw winning
chances because I I do have a c4 which
is far more advanced than any of his
pawns and his King is still more
vulnerable than mine I thought this work
at four move was actually a really nice
one because basically I if I play like
rookie seven first then he kind of gave
the tempo so I'm playing with that for -
actually - same same position isn't it
yeah the inches like 47 yes exactly same
position I just realized I'm confused I
thought working for is clever but it's
exactly the same thing oh you can be
forgiven for that in the time pressure
you are in I don't even know how you
think about anything in that moment it's
such a critical time in the game yeah my
my thought process was strange I thought
like rook F or King g8 look at fate King
g7 I thought that's a tempo up right
because the fingers on g7 rather than g8
maybe but anyway I still think that he
has a lot of problems to solve here
I assume it's objectively a draw but
it's still very unpleasant and at this
point he had like 10 seconds right yeah
10 seconds - yeah but my plays were easy
I just played 67 I see by the way
there's a finish here as we push forward
as you realize your pawn was rushing
down the board I hear the opportunity
after c7 to plate the move a3 what were
you gonna do if he had yeah this was a
law I have to play with a three-inch is
actually found work a five check as a
rookie who's obviously very strong
winning but Rick 80-85 check is another
no but stupid because I could have taken
I for the move before I don't take upon
any way that's true which what's really
answered but anyway I mean besides that
one miss at the end I I think it was
part of the goodness Wow
well we could say not just a good game
entertaining game from our standpoint
and now you have two trips to London to
make you'll be playing for the World
Championship and also for the grand
chests or title your year has been just
astonishing and it actually started in
London last year the end of London 2017
when you won a playoffs against the from
the achi to take the title of the London
chess classic that was the first
tournament you had one ahead of Magnus
in many a year in fact yeah bicycle
tournaments is you won in 2014 that's
correct now you've got this great year
it's continuing how are you are you
doing it I don't know I'm I'm not really
doing anything different later than the
night was before but everything is going
is going very well I mean I decide okay
I had some rough tournaments in the
middle of the year and Harrison living
but besides out the year has been pretty
much more than I could have ever
expected you get to rest you get to the
Olympia next what are you gonna do in
between oh I still have a lot of chests
work to do so although I will be resting
there will also be a lot of work done as
well but I am glad to at least not have
to play any more games for about a month
each ask is to be board one again and
you won the title the gold medal you
also want a personal bronze in the
tournament itself for the Olympia that's
board one representative the US team I
know Wesley's dejected now but she to
about to become real teammates again as
he won gold individual gold on board
three it should be great to team up
again with the boys yeah this time we
have an even stronger team I mean we
have the same players but Sam has
improved both his play it seems and his
rating quite a lot so I mean we
definitely have a shot at gold again but
it's it's gonna be very tough so whether
or not we'll make it I can't be sure
your feeling about playing in st. Louis
it's home for you you live like two
blocks from here now the the kind of
love you get in this city
oh this tournament it's been exceptional
um I mean especially like after I drew
against Magnus I got an a standing
ovation basically as I walked down which
was a first for me because it was
actually it was just a draw but but I I
appreciate it I appreciate all the
support I got especially during this
tournament and last word about this
thing feels and what they've done for
chess yeah it's I mean it's been great
this tour which started with an idea in
st. Louis has has turned into I mean
such a such a huge thing all the top
players involve competing and fighting
for just a few spots and final in London
and I mean this tournament had a
slightly higher percentage of draws and
then we would expect but I still think
it was exciting especially the last
round I mean you can can't really hope
for more than than what we had
I mean Levin's getting booed takes up
seven was one of the most gangster moves
I've ever seen in my life and and yeah
it's been great overall the Justice
rebirth of chess and st. Louis Oh
congratulations magnificent performance
in both the Sinquefield Cup and
regarding us here in this last tie break
good luck with everything
thank you what can we say
congratulations Bobby it was thrilling
I love the gangster gangster reference
and congratulations on all your success
from Jennifer and myself it's just been
great
and here's the move that really changed
everything in the game rook a 1 to a 2
from pawn down and the defensive
position this move eventually restored
material equality and carried fabbi
to his eventual success that's right it
was all trending upwards after RIPTA 82
exactly so yeah but let's review
Jennifer I mean Wow
let's go through all the participants of
the signal problem here we have Sergei
carjacking
not have the best tournament in the
Ziegfeld Cup but even in the last round
we've so we saw shades of his greatness
as the Minoru defense held on against
Maxine boxer in the garage two ponds
down and a real compelling game hikaru a
very very sour note even though he's our
grand gesture door number one seed who
lost the final game against Magnuson and
also our student was rapping and blitz
champion we also have Wesley so who
ended up fighting so hard against Aviano
for that fourth spot but came just ever
so close and failed but always a
pleasure to have Leslie so in the
tournament so solid that's really
playoff I know that we just witnessed
tonight him as road to London
finally Maxine Basheer the grab 9 draws
but not for want of trying
especially in the last game he kept
fighting and ended up getting third on
the grand chest for allowing him to find
a birth to London with no face Levon
Aronian exactly oh and what about what
can you say about Alex Grisha can
absolute star in the postgame interviews
so funny so enterprising knowing that he
needed to win one of his last two games
and possibly both of them he want to
show yeah yeah he really risked
everything went all out he came up short
only because LaVon played like absolute
genius
we had vision Jana and it's so great to
see a vision in st. Louis it's one of
his favorite places to play chess and
she loved having them also 9 draws it
was the draw bug that he fought tooth
and nail with everybody else it was just
extraordinary that he didn't get a
victory out of one of those positions
that he pellet and we have shot your
mama tiara
Wow yes Louis rapid in glitz and he came
close as well razorsharp Singh field Cup
and also giving him the grand chest for
finals ever so close a shocker er mama D
ro is actually just a point away from
finding himself in the playoff with a
wedgie and five
that last spot what that rapid and
Blitzen and st. Louis might have done
just one point and the other here we
have our first co-champion Fabiano
carolina what a year World Championship
qualifier qualifier for the grand
chester also in london Sinquefield pop
two-time champion now the the excitement
and the accolades for this young man
this year just keep growing and $55,000
in the grand gesture finals in London
Magnus Carlsen well everybody loves to
watch Carlsen playing and he showed us
why during sync build Cup even though he
drew 87 at the first eight games right
not so hard every game and he finally
the ultimate grinder got it done in
Nakamura in a position that almost
everyone thought was gonna be a job
absolutely but it's his bread-and-butter
and he's the number one player in the
world and world champion for a reason
and now also a two-time sync Theo Cup
champion and the Joker of the park
Fabiano Kurata his fellow co-champion
called him a big gangster chess for
playing rook takes f7 a move that
certainly delighted that's all
congratulations to LaVon now he can also
say that he's got his name on two
Sinquefield cups congratulations and
it's gonna be a little crowded on the
cup this year although I understand that
they're all gonna get trophy
Fabiano Kurata Levon Aronian and magnus
carlsen are our code champions and three
such extraordinary inspirations all very
different yet such a hard worker and
great all-around player down to earth is
Fabi
LaVon incredibly funny just brought it
when it mattered and Magnus like I said
before the ultimate grinder yeah well I
didn't know we were gonna have a repeat
winner it's extraordinary that we had a
three-peat winner
it's pretty amazing tournament Maurice
and look at our predictions yeah sorry
to rub it in but
every except for you tell you something
I I'm happy to go down with the ship
with Shaq I thought he brought it he
made me proud for my pick it's a good
pick it was a good pick incredible
wait a minute wait not good luck in
November I'm coming back in a week for a
Fisher 960 we'll talk predictions then
sorry Maurice let me tell you it is such
a thrill to watch high-level chess and
to have this seat to be able to watch
the games intimately to talk about them
to parse them to guess at winners to
guess it moves to see the best players
give it their all sometimes they fail
spectacularly and sometimes they play
such brilliant moves that you are just
in awe and we saw all of it in this
tournament yes there was a very low win
ratio but you definitely saw the players
fighting it out desperate for victory
wanting to win that passion was there
there were no simple GM draws as these
players show the importance of the C
field Cup and the grand chest tour
itself and for me it's a pleasure it's
been great it's amazing that it's over
working with you guys gets better and
better we're not just a team but a
family and work with everyone else here
in st. Louis what an amazing place to be
in for the world of chess and personally
for my career and I'm glad I'm coming
back in about ten days right Maurice
thank you if I can get in the final word
as well for me I'll tell you something
it was not just a historical moment but
there was something incredibly special
about the Sinquefield Saturday this club
man was filled to the raft
there's people were in line I mean that
fabbi just talked about it I mean they
didn't they didn't carry him down the
street but they gave him a standing
ovation for a draw the young piano that
are starting to come into chest because
of him get more interested and what a
great role model he is as well as our
other top American players
so when Nakamura and really all the
players in the Sinquefield cups I mean
you know you can really pick your idol
here because they're all just great
players and people to emulate yeah bad
scene Phil Saturday that just that was
just so special Wow excellent sorry we
have our showdown coming up just let's
talk about that for a quick search for
those of you who are worried about is
coming up in just two weeks
Gary Kasparov is going to be returning
to the game making a comeback playing in
as exciting format where the pieces are
shuffled in the back row I love it I got
my picks already you also got Nakamura
versus viddler Solvers Gary Shanklin our
US Champion playing against Maxine back
here the grab and Levon Aronian against
Owen Year Dominguez another match that
I'm particularly thrilled to call in
just two weeks yes 5 great games great
matches and the positions will be
changed every four games so we'll have a
unique starting position for every game
it's just fantastic yeah you know for
every four games it's it's gonna be
great I'm looking forward to calling
that one as well indeed and we do want
to remind you all that if you missed
anything field cup champions because of
you no obligations with work or family
they're actually all archived on YouTube
Fran Chester org but then also subscribe
to see with Chess Club along with
another 170,000 people or so doing the
crowd during the crew and you can watch
instructional videos as well as all the
archives of these thrilling three weeks
that we've had in st. Louis I would like
to give a couple of thank yous as
sure I'd also just want to remind we
will we be streaming the closing
ceremonies yes we are okay at 6:00 p.m.
here in st. Louis so that's 7:00 p.m.
East Coast okay and they're Salem now
the thank you sorry thank yous two of
silverback and two a spectrum studios
and the staffs at the st. Louis chess
club and the world chess Hall of Fame as
well as of course our arbiters and
everybody who made this happen fighters
we really appreciate the fans o most
especially I love signing the
Sinquefield book it was always great and
no I really want to also say thank you
so much to the st. Louis chess club the
staff has just been wonderful catering
to all of our needs thank you all and
we'll be back in just a couple weeks so
don't miss a minute we'll be back in a
couple of hours we're late for the
closing ceremony thank you all very much
for joining us until next time
[Music]